Trascrizione: Milena Tavano
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
A chi di voi è capitato nell’ultimo anno
di fare un acquisto online e pentirsene?
Vi chiedo di alzare le mani.
Un’altra domanda: a chi di voi è capitato
di aprire l’armadio e chiedersi
“Ma esattamente cosa avevo nella testa
quando ho comprato quella roba?”
Qui le mani sono molte di più.
È un’esperienza condivisa, perché vedete:
le aziende sono molto brave oggi
nel settare una serie di stimoli
che ci fanno acquistare.
Sono brave perché esiste una disciplina,
ovvero delle neuroscienze
un campo che studia esattamente
cosa accade nel cervello che acquista
grazie allo studio
delle micro espressioni facciali
come questa macchina che vedete qui dietro
oppure per capire in un sito web
dove va la nostra attenzione
con un eye tracking.
Ora, in realtà con le neuroscienze
si è in grado di capire
o si sta cercando
sempre di più di capire
cosa accade tra lo stimolo e l’acquisto.
Perché sono qui oggi?
Beh, ho due obiettivi.
Il primo è raccontarvi che cosa
si sa oggi sul cervello che compra.
Il secondo è condividere con voi
tutta una serie di sistemi, di tecniche
per non farci manipolare
o decidere se, quanto e come
farci manipolare quando acquistiamo.
Vedete:
in realtà sappiamo molto
sul cervello che acquista.
Tutto quello che è intorno a noi
è una serie di stimoli:
parole, colori...
tutti questi stimoli vengono frullati
e arrivano al talamo
e il talamo li spedisce
immediatamente al limbico.
Cos’è il limbico? Il limbico
è il cuore del nostro cervello.
E immediatamente il limbico
manda il segnale ai neuroni motori
che decidono se compriamo o non compriamo.
La corteccia arriva molto dopo:
alcuni studi dicono millisecondi dopo
ma alcuni studi dicono addirittura
alcuni secondi dopo.
Ovvero, in sostanza la corteccia,
il raziocinio, la logica
arriva a giustificare un comportamento
che in realtà il limbico
ha preso in autonomia.
Il limbico è pre-verbale:
si basa sulla fiducia e sulle emozioni.
Quindi un mix di stimoli ci dice:
“ok, mi fido, ok sento qualcosa” e compro.
La corteccia arriva solo a giustificare.
Tutti noi ad esempio
compriamo per il Black Friday
pensando che la leva sia il risparmio,
una leva logica: non è così.
È il rimpianto: il rimpianto
di non trovare più quel prodotto.
Tutti noi pensiamo di essere vaccinati
a quelle famose frasi che escono:
“ancora pochi posti disponibili
per questo hotel”
oppure “già 300 persone
hanno visto questa location”.
In realtà non lo siamo,
perché queste frasi ci attivano.
Perché? Perché abbiamo paura di perdere,
e la paura è un’emozione.
Ma, vedete, la manipolazione è ovunque.
Un recente studio ci dice
che se il personale di sala
quando prende la comanda
ripete le nostre parole
esattamente le parole
che ha detto il cliente
arriviamo a spendere fino al 20% in più.
Perché? Perché ci fidiamo di più,
ci sentiamo meglio.
Ora, la manipolazione,
quando parliamo di acquisti, è ovunque.
E cosa fare quindi?
Ci sono due tipi di acquisti
nella nostra vita:
acquisti quotidiani
e acquisti ad alto impatto.
Cominciamo dai primi.
Quando noi compriamo qualcosa,
riuscire a gestire la
manipolazione è veramente difficile.
Proviamo però a ragionare
in maniera diversa.
Tutti noi in questi due anni abbiamo
vissuto momenti di privazione:
lockdown, zone colorate...
E quanto è bello comprare?
Quanto è bello andare in un negozio,
poter lasciar andare il pilota automatico?
Quanto è bello andare su un sito
e-commerce e fare click?
Ora, la verità è che per certi versi
la manipolazione è positiva. Perché?
Perché le aziende vogliono esattamente
farci fidare di loro
e farci sentire meglio.
Non possiamo resistere e sapere
che non possiamo farlo è la cura migliore.
E cosa fare allora?
Beh, semplicemente decidiamo
quanto farci manipolare
e quindi la tecnica dei due budget,
dei due conti correnti,
delle due carte di credito.
Quindi io decido quanto farmi manipolare.
Ora, è come un po’ un giocatore d’azzardo
che sa già che non riuscirà a controllarsi
e quindi decide che andrà
al casinò solo con una certa cifra.
Beh vedete poi ci sono, però, acquisti
nella nostra vita che hanno un impatto
acquisti che cambiano la nostra vita.
Compro una casa? Beh, mi sto indebitando
per i prossimi 30 anni.
Il modo in cui gestisco i miei risparmi
avrà un grande impatto per il mio futuro.
Ecco, questi sono gli acquisti
dove non dobbiamo farci manipolare.
Questi sono gli acquisti
dove dobbiamo spegnere il limbico
e attivare la corteccia.
Come fare?
Anche qui possiamo usare alcune
tecniche pratiche. La prima: rimandare.
Ovvero, di fronte a un acquisto importante
procrastiniamo la decisione
rimandiamo, perché altrimenti veniamo
manipolati inconsapevolmente.
Secondo: dati.
È difficile trovare dei dati.
soprattutto dei dati oggettivi.
Però già il fatto di approcciare
un acquisto guardando dei numeri
attiva la razionalità,
attiva la corteccia,
attiva la parte più nobile del cervello.
Consigli, quando facciamo
acquisti di impatto?
Sì, ma solo se siamo certi
che le persone che ce li stiano dando
non vogliano, anche in maniera
inconsapevole, manipolarci.
E poi forse la tecnica più importante,
la meno conosciuta:
Il pessimismo, sì.
Quando facciamo un acquisto importante
dobbiamo metterci nell’idea di:
“Cosa succede se sto sbagliando?”
Vi voglio fare un esempio: immaginiamo
che decida di comprare una casa.
Ok, prima cosa che devo fare:
non scelgo subito, rimando.
Sì perché quel caminetto
mi porta un po’ lontano.
Dati: ok, a quanto si comprano
e si vendono le case in quell’area?
A quanto si affittano?
Consigli? Parenti e amici, hm.
Chiediamo a chi ci vive, in quella zona.
Pessimismo:
se le cose vanno male, sono in grado
con l’affitto di riuscire a compensarlo?
Ecco, questo è solo un esempio
di come una modalità di acquisto
sui beni importanti
possa essere davvero significativa.
Ora, vedete,
io mi occupo di queste cose.
Due settimane fa
sono uscito a cena con mia moglie
perché festeggiamo dieci anni insieme.
Allora ho ordinato
una bottiglia di vino importante
insomma l’occasione lo meritava.
Una bottiglia di vino di quelle costose.
Devo dire che era buonissima.
Insomma abbiamo passato una bella serata.
Il giorno dopo ero in ufficio e pensavo:
“Ma davvero era così buona
quella bottiglia?”
E mi è venuto in mente
uno studio di un ricercatore californiano
un certo Rangel, il quale qualche anno fa
aveva dimostrato che quando noi ordiniamo
una bottiglia cara, costosa
si attivano le aree orbito-frontali
che ce la fanno percepire
effettivamente più buona.
Insomma per tutto il giorno mi domandavo
se davvero quella bottiglia e quel vino
fosse stato così buono.
In realtà per saperlo
avrei dovuto berlo come fanno i sommelier
cioè blind, all’oscuro.
Invece il prezzo, la cantina famosa,
la scena del sommelier
chissà quanto mi avevano manipolato.
Insomma questo pensiero
mi ha accompagnato tutto il giorno.
Poi sono tornato a casa,
abbiamo messo a nanna le nostre tre bimbe
e mia moglie mi ha dato un bacio
e mi ha detto:
“Sai che la bottiglia di ieri sera
era davvero fantastica? Grazie.”
E allora ho pensato:
“Beh a volte è bello farsi manipolare il
cervello ma solo se sai quando farlo.”
Grazie.